WHY THE W.H.O. MISMANAGE AND
COVER UP CORONAVIRUS.
JOINING ME NOW FOX NEWS
CONTRADICT TORE FORMER SOUTH
CAROLINA CONGRESSMAN TREY THAT’S
HUGE IF THEY CAN GET THIS
THROUGH CONGRESS AND YOU CAN
ALLOW AMERICAN CITIZENS TO FILE
LITIGATION AGAINST THE COMMUNIST
CHINESE, THAT’S A GAME CHANGER.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT CHANCES
ARE THAT THAT HAPPENS?
>> IN THIS POLITICAL ENVIRONMENT
THEY WOULD BE REALLY GOOD AND
TOMMY AND DAN ARE TO BE
COMMENDED WITH WE NEED A CHANGE
BECAUSE OF THE ACT THAT MAKE IT
IS IMPOSSIBLE TO SUE OTHER
COUNTRIES AND U.S. DISTRICT
COURT.
YOU STILL JESSE HAVE THE
CHALLENGE OF GETTING THE
INFORMATION FROM CHINA, THAT
DISCOVERY AS WE CALL IT IN THE
LEGAL REALM, AND THEN THE
DAMAGES.
I MEAN IF YOU’VE LOST YOUR LIFE
OR LOST YOUR BUSINESS,
OR SUFFERED INJURY, YOU’RE
ENTITLED TO DAMAGES BUT YOU HAVE
TO COLLECT.
SO THAT INDIVIDUAL ROUT IS ONE
WAY TO GO.
THERE’S ALSO A NEED A
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE WORLD TO
HOLD CHINA ACCOUNTABLE.
I MEAN, IF YOU CANNOT WARN OTHER
COUNTRIES THAT A PANDEMIC HAS
BEEN UNLEASHED, YOU HAVE NO
BUSINESS BEING A LEADER ON THE
WORLD STAGE.
SO THERE’S THE INDIVIDUAL,
THERE’S THE WORLD AND THEN
THERE’S WHAT OUR COUNTRY CAN DO
AND I THINK WHERE WE CAN HIT
THEM HARDEST THERE --
IS TO IS TO OSTRACIZE THEM AND
RECLAIM OUR MANUFACTURING
RECLAIM OUR PHARMACEUTICAL
MANUFACTURING IN PARTICULAR.
THERE ARE LOTS OF WAYS WE CAN
HOLD CHINA ACCOUNTABLE.
JESSE: I TOTALLY AGREE WITH THAT
BECAUSE IF THE SHOE WERE ON
OTHER FOOT THERE WAS AMERICAN
COMPANY THAT WAS DOING DANGEROUS
RESEARCH AND SPREADS THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD CAUSING MASSIVE
ECONOMIC PAIN AND EVEN DEATH
DEARN THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
HAD HAD TRIED TO COVER THAT
UP --
I MEAN THEY WOULD HAVE BROUGHT
TRUMP IN FRONT OF THE HADE AND
BROUGHT HIM UP ON WAR CRIME
CHARGES THAT’S HOW SIGNIFICANT
WOULD HAPPEN IN CHINA IS IN NOW
W.H.O., YOU KNOW, JUST SO PEOPLE
KNOW THIS GUY HAND PICKED OUT OF
ETHIOPIA FROM CHINESE THIS GUY
ACTUALLY GAVE A GOODWILL
AMBASSADORSHIP TO ZIMBABWE.
I MEAN, THAT’S JUST THE THOUGHT
PROCESS BEHIND THE GUY THAT’S
ROTTING W.H.O. NOW WE HAVE
CAUGHT FUNDING LAUNCHING AN
INVESTIGATION WHAT DO YOU THINK
THIS INVESTIGATION IS GOING TO
FIND AND --
EVEN IF IT FINDS THAT THEY WERE
ACCOMPLICE WHAT DO WE DO ABOUT
IT?
>> WE CONTRIBUTED A LOT OF THAT
MONEY SO WE CAN AND SHOULD CUT
OFF THE MONEY.
I THINK THERE OUGHT TO BE AN
ENTITY THAT COORDINATES
PANDEMICS.
BUT LET’S LOOK AT THE W.H.O. AND
TRACK RECORD FROM THE INCEPTION
OF THIS VIRUS.
THEY FIRST TOLD US THAT IT COULD
NOT BE TRANSMITTED HUMAN TO
HUMAN.
E THEN THEY TOLD US WE DIDN’T
NEED FACE MASKS.
JESSE I MADE A D IN THE LAST
SCIENCE CLASS YOU DON’T NEED TO
GIVE ME $4 BILLION TO TELL YOU
EXACTLY THE YOUNG INFORMATION.
I’LL DO IT, I’LL DO IT FOR FREE.
AND THEN ALL OF THE HEELS OF
TELLING US IT COULDN’T BE
TRANSMITTED AND THEN THEY GAVE
US THIS STELLAR PIECE OF
EVIDENCE DON’T SNEEZE ON SOMEONE
OR SNEEZE INTO YOUR ELBOW THAT’S
WHAT WE GOT FOR $4 BILLION TWO
THING THAT ARE WRONG AND ONE
THING THAT OUR MOMS TOLD US.
>> WOW.
WOW.
THAT’S AN EXPENSIVE PIECE OF